Es ist wirklich verrückt welche Rekorde alles
Elon Musk alle schlägt. Beim Jungfernflug
oder besser Start der Falcon Heavy war extrem
seltsam Fracht an Board, die eigentlich im
Weltraum gar nichts zu suchen hat. Ein Tesla
Roadster und auf dem Fahrersitz Starman. Eine
Puppe in einem Raumanzug und diese zieht jetzt
ihre Kreise durch das Sonnenensystem. Aber
wo ist sie? Das werde ich immer wieder gefragt.
Hier der aktuelle Stand. Bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction, den Elon Musk-Chroniken. Hier gibt
es täglich krasse Science-Videos abonniert
den Kanal nur und nur dann verpasst ihr keine
Video. Herzlich willkommen.
Schon beim Start gab es wilde Spekulationen.
Wohin fliegt Starman nur?Landet er auf dem
Mars? Oder wird er irgendwann einmal auf die
Erde stürzen? Oder wird er jetzt ganz unspektakulär
durch den Weltraum fliegen? Unspektakulär
ist ja in diesem Zusammenhang vielleicht der
nicht so ganz richtige Begriff. Mit seinem
Tesla Roadster als Testfracht für den Erstflug
der Falcon Heavy hat Elon Musk die Welt so
richtig aus der Fassung gebracht. Ein Auto
im Weltraum? Crazy! Und mit dabei der Hitchhikers
Guide through the Galaxy, die Musik Space
Oddity von David Bowie aus der Stereoanlage
und natürlich einem Handtuch um Handschuhfach.
Viele Grüße an Douglas Adams. Absolut irre
war das. Aber wohin fliegt dieses ungewöhnliche
Raumfahrzeug jetzt eigentlich? Von Elon Musk
waren bisher nur widersprüchliche Aussagen
zu hören. Zum Mars, zum Asteroidengürtel.
Und das alles scheint nicht zu stimmen. Jonathan
McDowell vom Harvard-Smithsonian Center for
Astrophysics in Cambridge (US-Bundesstaat
Massachusetts) die bisher bekannten Daten
analysiert und weiß jetzt wohin der Tesla
unterwegs ist. Und eins ist sicher: Daran
wird sich nichts mehr ändern. Der Treibstoff
ist verbraucht. Der Kurs kann nicht mehr geändert
werden. Der Tesla ist nach seinen Berechnung
in eine elliptische Bahn rund um die Sonne
eingeschwenkt, so wie alles, was hier so im
Sonnensystem durch die Gegend fliegt, Planeten,
Asteroiden und jegliche Himmelskörper. Dabei
liegt der sonnenfernste Punkt etwas außerhalb
der Marsumlaufbahn. Darüber haben wir ja
berichtet. Und genau diesen Punkt hat er jetzt
erreicht. Er ist am weitesten von der Sonne
entfernt und ist eben auch weiter als der
Mars von uns entfernt, nämlich 287 Millionen
Kilometer. Wow. Und das kann auch genau verfolgt
werden auf der Webseite „Whereisroadster.com“.
Den Link findet ihr im Infotext zum Video.
Damit ist der Roadster das Auto, das am meisten
Kilometer zurückgelegt hat, überhaupt. Space
X hat dazu eine Grafik auf Twitter veröffentlicht
mit der aktuellen Position. Text: „Next
stop, the restaurant at the end of the universe“
Nächster Stop, das Restaurant am Ende des
Universums“ wieder ein Gruß an den Autor
von „Per Anhalter durch die Galaxis“ Douglas
Adams. Wenn es neues zu seiner Position geben
sollte oder er irgendwo einschlagen sollte,
dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier. Denn
die Chancen gibt es tatsächlich. Mit 6prozentiger
Wahrscheinlichkeit schlägt er auf der Erde
ein…..in der nächsten eine Millionen Jahren.
Okay…..